You guys, humanity is
another step closer
to harnessing the nuclear
powers of the sun.
[MANIACAL LAUGH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey guys, Trace here, for
DNews, with some engineering
and physics that might
change the world.
A lot of time, we
get you on here
and we talk to you
about those things.
They're more conceptual
and sometimes
really complicated
and kind of jargony.
Whoosh.
But this, oh man, this is juicy.
This week scientists
announced that they
can produce many suns--
seriously, for real this time.
I know, they've been saying,
give us 30 more years
and we'll have it.
They might have been
closer than they thought.
We are close to solving
the mystery of fusion power
that keeps the Sun going.
While nuclear fission
gets a bad rap,
nuclear fusion is
completely different.
It's one of the holy
grails of science.
Fusion offers a near limitless
pollution-free cheap source
of energy.
The deuterium to
power the reaction--
harnessed from seawater.
And it's waste is the
super-rare helium 3 or helium 4
or perhaps more deuterium--
plus ideally, hundreds of times
more energy than we put in.
No big deal.
The best part, we get all of
this with no more radiation
than we're exposed
to in an average day.
Fission involves using
heat and pressure
to split an isotope of uranium.
Fusion involves combining
two atoms into one.
Both release huge
amounts of energy.
But the whole fusion thing,
so much more efficient.
The National
Ignition facility has
used 192 laser beams to
create an x-ray pocket
inside of a 77-ton machine.
The pocket super heats the
hydrogen deuterium fuel
and excites the particles.
As hydrogen has a
positive charge,
atoms normally repel each other.
But inside that pocket,
as the small piece of fuel
burns at 100 million
Kelvin, they move so fast,
they slam into each other,
fusing and creating new atoms,
releasing massive amounts
of energy in the process.
This is amazing stuff.
While these scientists
have confirmed
that they can create this
reaction for a microsecond,
they can't sustain it.
And without sustaining
it, they won't
be able to use it to
create electricity.
They say we haven't perfected
that little pellet of deuterium
fuel.
It's microscopically uneven.
And those imperfections cause
it to burn up too quickly.
But never mind that.
Even though we're not
sure how it works,
the EU, the US, China, India,
South Korea, and Russia
are all funding a single
fusion plant in France,
separately from the NIF.
It's a different design, but
here's to hoping one of them
gets this to work,
because I could
use some cheap, clean
energy right about now.
So there's one tiny little
thing that I probably
should point out.
Scientists are saying
that we are about 30
years from flipping the
switch on a power plant,
so there's that.
But hey, let's be
optimistic, right?
Guys?
Are you on board with
this fusion power thing,
or should we just
forget it and stick only
to renewables and other
proven technologies?
Let us know your power
thoughts in the comments.
And be sure you
subscribe for more DNews.